a lot of women have been conditioned to
believe that the guy is supposed to make
the move and I would say well if you
think that's old-fashioned you don't
know what old-fashioned really is a
hundred years ago a woman might walk
past a guy find him attractive and
inadvertently drop her handkerchief in
front of him he would see it pick it up
and think this is an extraordinary
opportunity to be a man and he'd take it
over to and he'd say Madam you dropped
this and and she would say did I and
they would now have a conversation he
may have felt he was being the proactive
one but she had initiated that move she
was the one who made the move she just
made him feel like he was the one making
the move there seemed to be something
very interesting in that to me that okay
regardless of whether you think women
can or can't make the move of course
they can but it doesn't matter what you
believe if I can give you a way to be
proactive that kind of feels like it's a
bit under the radar then I'm gonna get
even people who feel like it's not my
job to make the move I'm even gonna get
them being proactive in ways they
haven't before